four o'clock every day is play test
which is basically like Church four
o'clock is that the true competitive
time when everyone gets in and scrappy I
get the build and I play at their desks
over here in the play lab which we have
behind me and play Halo 5 and I'm just
bang up it can definitely get heated at
times they have a lot of trash talkers
on the team of course you know I'm
swearing and cursing and blinding halo
kind of brings it out of you it also
escalates this this guy put a scumbag
move in my opinion don't take credit for
the worst name that came before you can
get really pissed off and they just
start yelling at each other just having
a great time and give them another one
Tamia a Spartan is speed power agility
this vision this myth of a Spartan has a
superhero completely wrapped in
technology that thousand-pound jet
fighter on legs or tank on legs you know
it's this total destruction machine you
see chief coming down out of orbit
hitting the ground and you know doing
all that stuff we want to bring that
into the gameplay itself
in typical halo you have the already
awesome sandbox of the weapon the melee
and the grenade we wanted to add these
Spartan abilities in as a fourth layer
that everyone has so it's equal footing
their baseline traits every single
person who wants them can have them you
sprint as fast as the other players you
jump as high as the other players you
clamber like they do what my end up
being on the most sort of overarching
abilities is thruster pack ability these
little retro rockets building your
Spartan armor can give you a speed boost
while you're running but you can use it
in midair jump up in the air and I turn
my stabilizers on these jets kick in
you can go back forward all directions
we're not really limiting these things
we're actually allowing you to change so
for me the thruster pack is awesome it
allows you to do other new moves as well
actually intense is the thing we call
the ground pound which is dashing down
on the ground and then creating this
kind of shockwave splash effect
when you jump up you actually can mount
on top of edges throughout the world
there's really satisfying things like
just about making a jump and hitting the
clamber button at the last second and
making it the way you felt like you
should have made it once you reach
terminal velocity with Sprint's you'll
get an indication and if you hit Crouch
during that time you will launch into a
slide you can slide into cover more
quickly you can slide into a kill with a
shotgun you kind of really have to make
an important decision on the battlefield
so once you gain that terminal velocity
you can use slide but you also can
choose to charge you hit your melee
button you just bash through anyone we
know like there are people that love
sprint and there are people that just
feel like sprint has no place in Halo
and so for us it was about how do we
balance that how do we counter that
we've connected it to your shield so
while you're sprinting your shields
don't recharge if they keep running
their shields will never come back up
and somebody else is going to take them
down I think that balance is really
interesting
Smart's Kolb fiction is actually it's
being built in the game since day one
you were doing it with the pistol it it
was cybernetically linked to your helmet
the Spartan would see what was
ultimately just a zoom every weapon now
has a zoom in holographic image comes up
it's all slick helps me with some types
of weapons especially rapid-fire weapons
in my case but otherwise I tend to just
aim and from the hip anyway
hipfire mode is accurate same as I ever
was if it becomes such that everybody
feels like they have to be using smart
scope in order to be competitive
then we've broken the game going to use
your smart scope and zoom in with any
weapon but you also can be discussed at
of it by the enemy there are so many
different tactics that come into play
and that's something that we've tried to
build into all of the abilities for Halo
5
finding a balance between making the
abilities accessible and making them
meaningful is is weirdly difficult but
we try to get as big a variety of
players and as we possibly can so we
have our protein playing obviously
protein has been amazing to have its
resource I've never had on the team
before where you have such a rabid vocal
community and then you bring some of
them in who are really good at the game
they do things that you would never
expect they find any any upper hand that
they can find in the game they're gonna
exploit and that's that's good that's
what we want to see because then we can
fill those holes and so we knew that if
we had those people on site that would
make our games so much better because we
would have all that knowledge it's a
really good shortcut to good test data
in terms of playing the pro team that is
a horribly demoralizing experience that
does not end well playing against pro
team basically just getting pounded on
brutalized you are this little baby
mouse and they are like this gigantic
Puma just batting you around and then
finally putting you out of your misery
that's not fun we're in the play lab
it's pros vs. dense this isn't happening
I wouldn't say I'm nervous it's more so
anxious I think
let's go
in the house one shot
they're all over the place one minute
I'm charging you their most weak
lay those guys then we should see that
understood pushing it let's go nothing
wait you're all alone try to ground me
are you gonna try next time elimination
but I'd probably I'd probably scold the
cheapest player that would probably mean
I do a lot of what I call play to win
we're kind of the old-school beta where
it's like our parents are a software
they isn't finished yet
honestly we're nervous about it right
like we think you think we've got it all
figured out and we're gonna throw it out
there and everyone's gonna break
so for us we come in we play the game
every day but there's only so many
people here at 3:43 there's only so much
we can do but now this is about opening
it up to the world tuning and balancing
is the core of the arena experience and
if we get that tuning wrong then we want
to hear about it taking that feedback
and trying to make the game better
that's that's what the data is all about
I mean when you get a bunch of creatives
there's always disagreements you might
want to dial that back you might want to
turn it up because that's what's great
about this beta we're getting this out
there for people to really try the
second that the beta goes live we're all
gonna be online playing with the fans
yeah my gamertag is DS you want some
come get it alright so for at least the
first two or three hours I expect to be
very competitive with the world before
they figure this game out good job I'm
gonna savor those two to three hours of
glory where I am stompin everybody else
at my own game and then they're going to
turn the tables on me and it's not gonna
be pretty
there's so much creativity everybody has
the same moves it's up to you how do you
employ them on the battlefield kind of
chaotic but at the same time tactical
decision making that everyone has at
their disposal and it is that chess
match hey Louis got a new set of teeth
I mean this game has got some fangs
you ready have you been practicing on
Scrubs